it could still be out there watching
waiting listening ever wonder who the
voices behind your favorite animated
characters belong to
nice to have you back the things fans
we're going to be giving you some of the
shocking facts about some of your
favorite movies today so hold on tight
behind every animation there are very
talented actors
and these actors might have to alter
their voices to match their characters
even better
that's why it's hard to imagine that a
lot of the time hollywood's biggest
names are the ones lending their vocal
talents for these roles
a-listers like will smith angelina jolie
and brad pitt are just the tip of the
iceberg when it comes to all the others
we're about to name drop
let's head straight in whether you know
this actress from her role as bellatrix
in the harry potter films or for her
musical talents as madame tinardier in
les miserables there's no denying that
helena bonham carter does creepy
extremely well and her talents aren't
only saved for live-action films either
not only did she voice lady toddington
in wallace and gromit the curse of the
wear rabbit but she lent her talents to
a pretty big
tim burton movie she's the voice behind
the haunting emily from the corpse bride
give the movie another watch we bet
you'll never be able to unhear her voice
now
maybe he's right maybe we are too
different
hollywood's finest angelina jolie is
sprinkled throughout a ton of big movies
including some huge animated features it
may be hard to imagine her bringing a
furry friend
or a fish to life in fact you'd probably
never associate her with the characters
we're about to tell you she voiced
her voice is behind the powerful master
tigress and kung fu panda
and lola from the early 2000s film shark
tale why are you really out here
did you recognize her voice dakota
fanning has been hanging around red
carpet since she was just seven years
old
so her being involved in voice work
isn't a huge shock however
the film she worked in might surprise a
few of you she was still young so her
voice is a little harder to recognize
she's actually the actress behind the
infamous coraline
you're not my mother the creepy
children's movie was just the stepping
stone to her playing the evil volturi
member jane in the twilight franchise
a lot of us probably haven't watched
disney's tarzan since we were kids so it
might be hard to remember just
exactly how this character sounds
sound familiar yet the voice behind jane
is actually minnie driver
we know we were also shocked suddenly
the monkey stops crying
and now i turn around and there's a
whole fleet of them what comes to mind
when we say mila kunis
you probably thought that 70's show
ashton kutcher things like that right
well what if we told you she's actually
an actress on one of the biggest
animated tv series ever
family guy probably never crossed your
mind when thinking of mila but she's
voiced meg griffin on the series since
1999.
you're such a good listener you're not
like the other boys
we'll give you a hint for actress lucy
liu while working on this animated film
she was co-stars with angelina jolie
you're right if you guessed kung fu
panda
any guesses on what character she
actually voiced master viper in the
franchise
she also worked in the tinkerbell films
as her fairy friend silver mist and
princess may in mulan 2.
good job after hannah montana
miley cyrus never really immersed
herself in the world of acting beyond
disney and her movie the last song
instead she gained more fame through her
music but there's one movie she starred
in that ended up being a pretty big hit
and yes you guessed it
it was animated she's the voice behind
penny in the children's film bolt
did you recognize her voice when you
first watched the film there he is
dr calico swamps and ogres may not seem
like this actor's vibe in real life but
they were actually a huge part of her
on-screen life
cameron diaz she's beautiful she's grace
she's also someone who happened to have
a huge role in the shrek franchise
she's princess fiona did you recognize
her voice while watching the films
true love didn't get me out of that
tower i did
brad pitt a classic hollywood heartthrob
has had years of experience in the
industry including the voice acting
industry
have you recognized his voice in
anything you've watched lately his voice
acting skills were featured in the movie
sinbad legend of the seven seas
he was actually sinbad himself speaking
of hollywood heartthrobs
next up is johnny depp these next three
characters he voiced are a far cry from
captain jack sparrow or willy wonka but
they're arguably just as iconic
believe it or not johnny had a small
part in spongebob squarepants voicing
the character jack kahuna but he was in
something even bigger
he was co-stars with helena bonham
carter in the corpse bride and voiced
the timid victor von dort he even went
on to star in his very own animated film
ringo
who would have thought
we all know how ecstatic everyone was
when will smith was cast as the genie in
the aladdin live action
but that wasn't his first time bringing
a children's character to life
we're betting you had no idea that he's
the voice behind oscar in the movie
shark tale
yep he was co-stars with angelina for
this film you swim
to the shark you say oh man that sharks
like crazy man
justin timberlake might have fans
swooning when he sings crimea river but
we wonder if they've ever checked out
how intriguing his voice acting can be
he of course brought his musical and
acting talents to the role of branch in
the movie trolls and his humor to the
yogi the bear film as boo boo
but wait until you hear this next one he
was also in shrek
he played arty heir to the throne in
shrek iii timberlake has
layers it could still be out there
watching
waiting listening mel gibson has been
slaying the animation game since before
some of us were even born
believe it or not he had a huge part in
the disney film pocahontas
he's john smith guys he also landed the
role of rocky in the film chicken run
cloudy with a chance of meatballs has to
be one of the more bizarre animated
films
and that's saying a lot but we're
betting it definitely would not have
been the same without the added edition
of this spunky actress
ever wonder who brought samantha sparks
to life well it's anna faris
oh jello's my favorite
adam sandler a true film legend he's
starred in so many hits we've lost count
he even owns his own production company
but his comedy transcends live action
and has been highlighted even in
animation
i don't say blah blah blah
know where that's from hotel
transylvania of course and it's the
voice of dracula played by adam himself
welcome to hotel transylvania
before fergie could get well
fergalicious she was actually a voice
actor
now her voice may have been a little
tricky to recognize considering she was
just a child
but now you'll never be able to unhear
it she voiced sally brown and a ton of
peanut specials including charlie brown
mandy moore's comeback and this is us is
nothing short of spectacular but before
even the hit drama came to be she made a
huge disney debut in the princess movie
tangled
she was rapunzel when will my life begin
is nothing like her early 2000s pop
music
but if you listen closely it's
definitely her come on pascal it's not
so bad in there
the back to the future franchise shaped
an entire generation and is still
a lot of kid's favorite movies today
while there has yet to be a reboot star
michael j
fox hasn't stopped inspiring kids he's
the voice actor behind stuart and stuart
little and even guest starred on phineas
and ferb as a character named michael
we're jealous of hugh jackman for
multiple reasons his voice his acting
abilities and the fact that he got to
star alongside both zac efron and
zendaya in the same movie
but what we're most jealous of is that
he starred in some pretty iconic
animated movies
did you recognize his voice in happy
feet as memphis or rotty and flushed
away
neither did we how did he get here oprah
isn't just a straight-up queen because
she ran a successful talk show
she also stars in a disney princess
movie and she should she's tiana's
mother eudora in disney's princess and
the frog
and kiss that little frog petition for
more oprah voice work anyone
who doesn't love watching whoopi
goldberg speak her mind on her talk show
the view
but you want to know what's even better
hearing her sass come to life through
on-screen characters
whoopi is the voice behind shenzi and
the lion king and stretch and toy story
3.
they may be side characters but her
vibes definitely shine through
the wall will ferrell has done it all
and yes that includes animated movies
he's the mastermind behind megamind did
that blow your mind
he's also in a lego movie voicing lord
business of course his characters never
stray far from his familiar comedic
personality
but it doesn't make his roles any less
epic i did it
matrocity is mine don't let some of his
more mature and serious roles throw you
off
you won't believe the character samuel l
jackson plays in the incredible films
he's the one the only frozone yep
he's behind the iconic line
where's my super suit it's safe to say
we'll never be able to watch these films
the same way again
did finding out the voices behind these
characters make you love the films more
or not so much
let us know which reveal was the most
shocking in the comment section below
don't forget to give this video a thumbs
up and hit that subscribe button if you
want to see more videos just like this
one
talk to you all soon
[Music]
you